[Music]
Sam hunt headlining the Bud Light
getaway festival in North Charleston
South Carolina et was exclusively with a
country star before the show he
explained why it's taking a while to get
a follow-up to his debut album it's been
four years since montevallo came out
what what is the status
yeah I've been I've been experimenting a
lot minor fellow was a product of you
know a few years of if you heard all the
music that I worked on before my novella
it was I mean it was so all over the
place and then I sort of found this
little miss thing with that records this
was a little recipe and I don't know I
have I've wanted to try to like do that
again because that was so fun to me not
to montevallo again but to create
something different and unique again and
that's hard to do and that's what I've
been trying to figure out how to do so
do you feel pressure because that was so
successful and now we have downtown's
dead
yeah I definitely feel that pressure
when I had those songs ready for
montevallo
I had such a certainty about putting
those songs on the record and putting
those out to the world and that's what I
wanted to say at that time and since
then I just haven't had that
confirmation in that conviction about
anything that I've worked on so far so
you're waiting for that
yeah there's such an expectation because
you know most artists put out records
over a couple of years and I'm just not
maybe as a prolific a writer as somebody
said about the 33 year old married
longtime love Hannah Lee Fowler last
April she inspired his first album and
is also played a part in his process
this time around
how does she inspire music is it
different now yeah it is I've been
looking for inspiration this past couple
years I'm a lot of that first record I
wasn't content in life and so I just I
felt like I had something to say because
I needed to prove myself but I'm so
content that I just don't turn to music
as often to like to validate myself I'm
gonna make you miss me
[Music]
makes it harder because you're so happy
yeah exactly it's like that um there's
plenty to write about it's been my
inspiration it's changed because my life
changed a lot she inspires me certainly
but the dynamic of our relationship now
compared to been and I've never read a
lot of love songs so now I feel like my
life's full of love and I don't really
know what to do with it I don't know how
to get that into a song I know how to
get the angst into a song if not I feel
like you have some good love songs in
you I'm waiting for those but there's
something else that may holds up the
music - how do you feel like you've
evolved over the past four years as a
man as an artist as a person involved in
a lot of ways I have a lot of
perspective that I did not have several
years ago and going through this
[Music]
experience as a small-town kid who goes
off to college if it learned picks up
guitar and goes and decides he wants to
become this or do this thing that I have
sort of idealized and realizing that
it's a lot it's not everything that I
exactly but I thought it that it was and
now I'm yeah I'm I'm really appreciating
all the little things that I say for
granted what I love as I read that you
were educating yourselves and like
reading all the time yeah that's
something - yeah well you know um I went
to college and and I didn't tune in to
my studies like I should have and I
started to get a little older and I
started to appreciate some appreciating
the value of knowledge and realizing how
much I should know that I don't would
you go back to school yeah at some point
yeah like online classes are actually go
I probably do something like yeah which
is becoming a more reasonable way to UM
to approach learning so yeah we'll see
you